how's it going my name is on fire
welcome back to some more happy hey oh
poor guy hey they are just sticking up
I'm a dolphin awkward silence
torso again way sorry uh gods are shot
Oregon's nice penis shape Tory hahaha
one three five kids one ring what
oh one we're done all right you can bait
em come on hard you can do Boop
congratulation hey not bad not bad at
all rainbow stared Rob that sounds
perfect oh I don't care go son
there we go whoa all right I'll take the
lid down it actually made me please
all right here I got rainbow stairs oh
no not for oh yeah back what is a god
damn it
Devin come after you and I'm not a good
idea
all right I'm gonna front flip whoa
all right here we go horse up are you
okay son looks like your dick alright
here we go
come on side waking day whoa gosh oh
[ __ ] god dammit how long does it go
has it ever stop until it pops oh there
it is
my legs made it come straight fives out
of you
my son whatever close enough close
enough mad - boom Brax choosing a new
county level there's a boom right after
I make all right you can throw it to me
for a faster time oh [ __ ] I said my head
that sniper huh
tell me I don't know what you're
thinking please don't do it
hey I'm a life welcome to the corner of
shame god damnit [ __ ] youth boxes I
can do I love his leg when it goes like
inside-out tiny City is saggin sexy girl
art oh girl look at that body from a
[ __ ] like this honestly when I walk down
this rescue your son likes ya that's
cool
you can go whoever you are stranger
thank you for this favor alright fine I
guess I gotta say that front flap shut
up you're not that's gonna rescue you if
you do that [ __ ] backflip ah back is it
doing
oh yeah doing his buzzer either way I
don't want em there you go buddy a dying
old man don't stop him from carrying on
and raping like raping please alright
come on
why do you dying go there we go thank
God
Thank You old man very well can all
right
see if I can do something about it
front flap yeah yeah not a problem not
happen what the hell is this [ __ ]
what's that you're supposed oh whoops
sorry about that I don't mean today
daddy will pay for the hood sad that
you're dead
all right go this back go that's bad
that's but what are you doing ah yes
this year me nervous bad for these
shapes what the hell ah baby and then
party whoa that's some trippy [ __ ] whoa
what the hell whoa what the hell okay
cool
desert disaster run buddy and you I can
sit down by Oh what the hell hey I got a
new necklace
I got damn it ah back back off mine
that's right
you know back with me [ __ ] oh [ __ ] yo
Joe [ __ ] yeah I don't up the spear
double speared God dad I know it's
always a [ __ ] bat just shut up and
enjoy the ride how this [ __ ] I've ever
thought about that that's done what are
your junks huh goddamn that piece of
[ __ ] all right here we go watch out for
the spares this time [ __ ] off whoa so
much space so much power [ __ ] [ __ ]
arrows that's what you get for being old
I'm having spares and [ __ ] Oh No
[Music]
not bad not bad man basketball slam dunk
I love these yeah don't move and hold
space [ __ ] God dad you wanna be doing in
the background you like slurping
election all right here we go
holding space I'm s oh oh boy this is
gonna be a big I'm gonna do that yeah
yeah yeah yeah you see this [ __ ] that's
how I roll
synchronized dance yeah super nice yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry only for
propo goes well I am a pro good luck
charger ah I get a leg I'm glad you made
it leg charge it Wow
why do I keep becoming indirect charge
it step it out house maybe yes maybe yes
I'm so glad I'm still alive no I'm not
really stop Harper I got damnit guess
they're not really that friendly one
more try
I wasn't even close
come on
oh I get it I did make it balanced it
done no more [ __ ] poker maps
hey pip ah brother
all right go wait hey hey what the hell
happened here oh don't move I'm sorry
all right here we go I'm doing the sound
effect that's probably not a good way
[Music]
ouch oh ah oh those does hey country bar
how's everyone then huh thanks hey I got
a new collar awesome no let go leave me
I made it thank upward spike challenger
to the awkward spike is a bit more
difficult I guess I just got to go in
the Sun go yeah about the head oh my god
that was a goodbye rage mode the hell
that is this [ __ ] yeah cat all them hey
that's my car I don't faze bad news
ain't no fight like a party [ __ ] hey
it's a squirrel what are you doing kid
well I'm riding him riding the squirrel
I'm riding everyone that [ __ ] kid
doing Baga charge it charge it and boom
oh no I'm it hey what's fun how you
dance I'm sorry what am i sorry [ __ ]
everyone just comes ain't no party like
a food fight bar I want to grab that
[ __ ] thing
hey hey how's it going squirrel hi you
there's Kyle
beaver your beaver yeah yeah they see me
rolling and they hump and I'm sorry
about your hair take back actually no
[ __ ] you head
[ __ ] you beaver tail [ __ ] yeah the [ __ ]
right synchronized dance my way out of
here there we go
no what are you dying ha oh let's see
[ __ ] today I am wait
are you doing molesting my butt or
something oh yeah oh yeah let me guess
somebody back
let me guess summer yeah Baga say hey
thank you have period can we get some of
that
the objective is [ __ ] mad I like that
one I thought it was very funny though
mmm
Joker you're never to get away with this
joker
Oh in the Batman you'll you'll never get
away with it bring out yeah that's why
they are dying stealing my fuzzies what
what'd I just say
now they're dead okay
I did my deck um I like obviously I'm
out he's falling through fast my arms
nice pink ha got you now Oh Joker oh how
did I not bad it out save the child die
you [ __ ] pedophile you want some
candy my little guy I got down sorry I
missed you gotta get draped son all
right there we go
ah I hit him in the wrong no no buddy
yeah there we go
ah god damn it I suck at this oh god
damn and that was not bad there we go
right in your deck now you can die ya
can't molest him without a deck that's
right and y'all face [ __ ] and your face
and your face goddamn it I want to hit
hit the kid that's right
now my left hand is like nope it's ugly
now alright so that was pretty much it
for today thank you favorite if you
enjoyed subscribe to come with Rosa day
and I'll see you next episode
[Music]
what at the [ __ ]
Oh
[Music]
I'm not I'm not Oh No